with the ever growing and fast paced
work atmosphere
faster delivery and shorter turnaround
time in the software development space
have become necessary for an
organization's growth short sprints and
frequent releases occurring every two to
three weeks require a distinct approach
and new team rules so the idea to
produce great quality output with
limited post production bugs have given
rise to devops organizations that have
chosen a devops culture have
successfully enhanced the speed
performance and quality of software
delivery so if you want to learn devops
and its powerful tools and switch your
career in devops we are here to help you
with that simply learns skill up course
on introduction to devops tools will
help you learn the fundamentals of
devops and modern devops tools with
examples and hands-on demonstrations for
free that's right you can kick-start
your journey by learning devops from
this introductory course free of cost
you can gain the essential skills and
also get a course completion certificate
simply learns introduction to devops
tools skill of course is designed by
industrial experts and experienced
trainers for beginners developers system
administrators as well as for it
managers some of the crucial tools
covered in this course are git jenkins
docker kubernetes ansible and more
you will learn what these tools are
their benefits how to install them and
understand their architecture and
working with hands-on examples the
duration of this course is 8 hours and
all the modules are self-paced video
lessons with 90 days of access to the
entire course
this allows you to learn at your own
pace and convenience after completing
the course you will receive a course
completion certificate by simply learn
this certificate can be highlighted in
your resume to cast the attention of
potential recruiters isn't that great
the national average salary for devops
engineer in the united states is over
105 000 dollars per year so what are you
waiting for head straight to our course
page and announce your career in devops
by enrolling in our free introduction to
devops tools course today sign up now
and get certified with simply loan the
link is in the description box
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here